[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux la première actualité c'est
évidemment la découverte de cette queue
de dinosaures à plumes dans l'ombre
birman du crétacé il s'agit du premier
fossile en 3d d'un dinosaure avec des
plumes
son attribution à un dinosaure se basent
primo sur la longueur de la queue qui
montre que contrairement aux oiseaux
l'animal en question n'avaient pas de
croupion et secundo sur la forme des
vertèbres qui apparaissent concave
ventre allemands comme chez les
dinosaures la morphologie des plumes
avec leurs ramifications interne et
disposés de façon asymétrique montre que
les barbus l'on évolué avant que les
ramifications ne fusionnent pour former
un axe central le rachis ce modèle
maintenant soutenue par ce fossile était
jusqu'à lors contestée par certains
spécialistes
pas de quoi ressusciter un dinosaure
néanmoins d'autant qu'il n'est pas non
plus impossible que ce fossile est
appartenu à un oiseau à la longue queue
en effet archéoptéryx ou encore
jeholornis sont des exemples démontrant
que certains oiseaux anciens n'avaient
pas de croupion à l'instar de leurs
ancêtres théropodes affaire à suivre
donc
en attendant des restes plus complet
provenant de ce site déjà devenus
incontournables dinosaures toujours avec
limur aux russes à dinosaures théropodes
dont on vient de démontrer que les dents
ne se renouveler plus chez les adultes
contrairement aux autres dinosaures et
aux crocodiles dont les dents se
renouvelle toute leur vie les adultes
limur aux eaux russes se retrouvait donc
édenté comme des oiseaux lee murray au
russe nous éclaire donc sur l'origine du
bec à vient et sur la façon dont les
oiseaux ont perdu leurs dents
remontant le temps jusque avant les
dinosaures il y à 2 155 millions
d'années quand vivait youtube bersia la
plus ancienne espèce venimeuse près de
100 millions d'années avant l'apparition
du tout premier serpent youtube bersia
possédait de larges des pressions sur
l'avant du crâne et des dents cannelés
qui suggère que cet animal posséder des
glandes à venin et une morsure capable
de l'injecter dans ses proies
cette très ancienne hypothèse vient de
trouver confirmation grâce à l'imagerie
par rayons x et aux technologies de
visualisation 3d
mes collègues et moi même avons en effet
été capable de mettre en évidence la
présence d'un fin réseau de canaux
passant par la fosse pour la glande à
venin et la reliant aux canines ainsi
que la présence d'un 6 ivre courbe et
est ornée d'une crête semblable aux
dents de certains serpents venimeux
cette découverte soutien
la possibilité que les mammifères
étaient et primitivement venimeux comme
let encore l'ornithorynque d'aujourd'hui
dirigeants nous maintenant vers la mer
avec la découverte de ce remarquable
squelette complet d'un requin fossiles
un cosmopolite eau douce dans le milieu
scène supérieur du pérou d'ordinaire ces
poissons cartilagineux ne se fossilise
pas ce qui rendrait déjà ce spécimen
particulièrement remarquable mais en
plus des fragments de son dernier repas
sont préservés dans la région de son
estomac
il s'agit là d'une chance incroyable
pour mieux comprendre la position de
cosmopolite audio un proche cousin et un
du requin blanc dans la chaîne
alimentaire et donc d'en savoir plus sur
les origines du plus grand des requins
prédateurs moderne hominidés pour finir
des études génétiques viennent de
montrer qu'une partie du système
immunitaire des populations européennes
actuelles est directement hérité de
celui de l'homme de néandertal
la réponse de notre organisme aux
infections seraient donc directement
liée à notre lointaine ascendance ainsi
qu'aux événements d'hybridation qui
eurent lieu entre nos deux espèces cette
étude illustre ainsi l'importance de la
paléontologie dans des disciplines aussi
diverses que la médecine et la santé
publique la curiosité de cette émission
ces bulles base aux russes fils auxi ron
un terreau abside d'ici no doubt vieux
de 255 à 260 millions d'années et dont
le nom est directement inspiré du
pokémon bulbizarre qui se dit bulbes
azor en anglais officiellement le nom
bilbao russe fait référence aux cornes
d'apparence bulbeuses de son crâne et
les sceptiques ne manqueront pas de dire
qu'il peut s'agir d'une simple
coïncidence
il n'en est néanmoins rien car son nom
d'espèce et phylloxéra qui signifie
littéralement tranche herbe qui est le
nom de l'une des attaques du bulbizarre
en même temps c'est vrai qu'ils ont
comme un petit air de famille pour la
rubrique vintage nous revenons en 1925
lors de la découverte en afrique du sud
du galet dit aux multiples visages
il s'agit d'un galets de rivière vieux
de deux millions d'années et qui fut
découvert lors des fouilles menées par
le paléontologue sud-africain remdh art
dans un site riche en australopithecus
ce galet porte un visage bien
reconnaissable sur l'une de ses faces la
présence de ce galet dans un gisement à
homininés fut interprété comme une forme
d'appréciation artistiques venant de ces
derniers en effet d'arte ne pense pas qu
australopithecus est sculpté le galet
par contre il provient d'une rivière qui
se trouvait à
trente kilomètres de là par conséquent
il a formulé l'hypothèse que cet
australopithèque husky trouvant une
ressemblance entre ce galet et un visage
l'a ramassée et transportée loin de sa
rivière d'origine pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient examiner ce galet et se
faire leur propre opinion à propos de
cette hypothèse sachez qu'il est en ce
moment en exposition au british museum
de londres jusqu'au 26 février
le coup de coeur de cette émission enfin
c'est l'ouverture au public le 15
décembre dernier de lascaux 4 la toute
dernière production ultra réaliste de la
grotte de lascaux réalisé grâce aux
toutes dernières technologies de
scanners laser pour plus d'infos et une
visite interactive cliquer sur les liens
qui sont dans la description la fois de
dernière minute celle annonce de la
découverte d'un talent à soutenir deux
portant un embryon dans son ventre
les thalasso cnid sont surtout connus
pour être des reptiles marins
archosaures du trias adapté à la vie
aquatique et possédant un long coup fait
de très peu de vertèbres ce qui les
distingue nettement des plésiosaures
cette découverte montre pour la première
fois que à l'instar des plésiosaures et
des ichtyosaures même les archosaures
c'est à dire la lignée menant crocodiles
aux dinosaures et aux oiseaux pouvaient
donner naissance à des petits sans
peindre 2 c'était paléo news merci de
l'avoir suivi tous les liens vers les
actus sont dans la description abonnez
vous pour ne rien manquer d'anciens à
très bientôt
[Musique]